Mi-na, you said your sister is a vegetarian, right?
Did she start being a vegetarian when she was born?
Or did she at some point later on decide to become one?
One of my close friends once tried to become a vegetarian after he saw images of slaughter, but failed.
He said that it was a really tough challenge.
Like myself, a meat - lover, I can't imagine myself eating vegetables only.
I don't think it's good for your health either.
You should get nutrition from all sorts of food;...
...meat, fruits, and vegetables to have a healthy diet.
People choose vegetarianism for a variety of reasons.
Different people follow different forms of vegetarianism...
..but a true vegetarian eats no meat at all, including chicken and fish.
One thing I know is that when a woman decides to become a vegetarian,...
...that might mean she wants to lose some weight, like my sister.
You know, instead of not eating anything for several days,...
...she would rather eat something that doesn't contain any fat or sugar.
But like you said, being a vegan means you are not eating enough carbohydrates, protein and of course fat.
So, I also think that it's not good for your health.
What you should do instead of adjusting your diet instantly is exercise on a regular basis.
This is a good way to keep your body healthy.